the gunshot wounds may slowly be healing
but the rifts tearing this young nation
apart seemed beyond repair weeks have
passed since renewed clashes between
government and opposition forces left
hundreds dead in South Sudan Emanuel was
shot while running for his life towards
this United Nations camp for displaced
in the capital Juba two friends who were
with him were shot dead when were trying
to run then God reporting numbers where
polling numbers been to was shot dead by
government forces then I was wounded at
barely the majority of the displaced
here are ethnic know where the tribe of
opposition leader Riek Machar but like
emmanuel many of those uprooted by the
most recent fighting are equatorial they
feel increasingly entangled in the messy
often ethnic politics of South Sudan's
conflict which started over two years
ago between mature and his rival
President Salva Kiir and ethnic Dinka it
is like a government soldiers is not
caring about citizen they do care but
they sought everybody then they try to
ask we are now running to union is
because you are going to join your
brothers the thing that take over here
is no further rebellion a suspected
rebel sympathizer Emmanuel no longer
feel safe to leave the camp but food and
shelter are in short supply he is just
one of thousands of new arrivals waiting
to be registered for weeks he has been
sleeping on the floor of this school
how we sleep going out here is not safe
because they are right now the
government soldiers even alpha lying
outside they're outside the defense when
you try to cross that end of sick point
then you get yourself killed when your
money then you get yourself rep for
these women the risks of leaving the
relative safety of the camp are all too
familiar when the UN ran out of food
last month they were left with a
wrenching choice to stay in what their
children starve or to get food from
outside and risk attacks by marauding
soldiers and when our for the fighting
erupted we were about to receive our
food rations so we got nothing after a
few days of fighting we got real
honorary as the women said after nearby
markets over 200 were raped well Wow
Inara after a few days the women went to
get food but the government soldiers
captured us they then raped the young
women they took all the food i bought
from the market the only reason they
didn't rape me is because I'm old lucky
in Connemara unborn a South Sudan slips
back into civil war many people here are
increasingly angry at the international
community for not doing more to end it a
peace deal signed last year has failed
to bring about a political solution to
the conflict threats of an arms embargo
and sanctions have remained just that
and last month's proposal for an African
union-led regional Protection Force has
been rejected by the government onymous
already has more than 12,000 soldiers
and increasing them in something that
will impinge on our sovereignty we will
not accept it even if approved by the UN
Security Council it's unclear if the
regional force could make a difference a
13,500 strong UN peacekeeping force has
been operating in the country for five
years but it has been widely criticized
for failing to protect civilians United
Nations peacekeeping forces seeing the
war erupted those weeks there we are
hiding India banker
because they have all the military
equipment they support approach a girl
foods from being looted by the MP by the
spla process there's now we are really
hungry because no one was able to
protect us intimo food in terms of being
killed while the international community
miles over its next steps many here fear
that the stage has been set for it
another cycle of violence for the
hundreds of thousands of displaced
across the country there is little hope
that their lives will return to normalcy
anytime soon